for the CDU it's the latest in a string
of dismal results there were flowers for
election loser frog henkel but Uncle
Michael knows that many in her party
blame her for the Berlin result the
Chancellor however refuses to change
course on her refugee policy even though
a recent opinion survey says more than
eighty percent of Germans want her to do
just that benyamin sands oil to dusty
mentioned this is supposed to mean that
people simply do not want to take in any
foreigners especially foreigners of the
Islamic faith then it contradicts our
Constitution our country's international
legal obligations but above all the
ethical foundation of Germany CDU as
well as my own personal convictions and
keygen the CDU and I cannot take that
course least myth keen but Mackel says
she will do everything she can to
prevent masses of migrants from flooding
into Germany again like last year the
AFD party chief seemed confident at her
press conference the Berlin victory
means the right-wing populist party has
won seats in ten state parliaments in a
row with double-digit results now the
party is aiming for Germany's federal
parliament the bundestag fall of course
we are planning to enter with very good
results we've already said many times
that we see ourselves getting in with
double digits fourteen or fifteen
percent that's what the latest opinion
polls suggests and there's
disappointment for the SPD the Social
Democrats tallied their worst ever
result in the capital yet as the
strongest political force they can
continue to govern in Berlin with mayor
Michelle moola party officials tried to
put a positive spin on the results
Michelle Milla has been campaigning for
a cosmopolitan diverse and likable girl
in doing so not only makes us friends
but we also suffer losses in times like
these but this attitude is the right one
to get title
the three party alliance in Berlin among
the SPD greens and the left parties now
looks likely the potential coalition
partners were in high spirits it would
be the first such alliance under SPD
leadership in Germany and some see the
results in Berlin as a sign of things to
come for Germany's next parliamentary
elections with the pressure on Angela
Merkel likely to increase